كافح اليائسون لتحرير
المناشف من القسوة التي
تنتظرهم ليس فقط للهروب ، بل من أجل البقاء
على قيد الحياة للبقاء على قيد الحياة ،
لذا يعرف الكثير من الإيرانيين جيدًا
المسار الذي سيؤدي إليه هذا
[الموسيقى
] إلى جحيم على الأرض لأولئك الذين يجرؤون على
المعارضة
إنه دليل النظام القمعي الذي تم
تجربته واختباره مرارًا وتكرارًا ،
يقول هذا المتظاهر البالغ من العمر 29 عامًا إنه تم
اعتقاله هذا الشهر وتحمل أربعة
أيام من التعذيب على يد الحرس الثوري الإيراني ،
وبدأ أحدهم يركل
بطننا ويضع رؤوسنا في
دلاء من الماء لذلك نحن  لم يستطع
التنفس وضربنا بخرطوم الحزام
والصدمات الكهربائية ، زعم أنه
أُجبر على التوقيع على اعتراف يقول
إنه دفع له من قبل الحكومتين الأمريكية والبريطانية والإسرائيلية
للتعبير عن الفوضى في
إيران ، وقد ترك ندوبًا
طفيفة تلتئم ولكن  ما لا نراه
قد لا يلتئم أبدًا
هذه الأيام ليس لدي الكثير من النوم
لدي كوابيس معظم الوقت في
كوابيسي أرى شخصًا ما يلاحقني
في الظلام  وأنا وحدي ولا أحد
يساعدني ويقول إن السلطات
لا تزال تلاحقه.
تلقيت مكالمة هاتفية من
رقم مجهول أنا نشط على تويتر ، لقد
هددني وعائلتي قائلاً إذا
لم تتوقفوا فسوف يفعلون ذلك.  اعتقلني
وأنني أعرف ما ينتظرني ،
إنه نمط من الاضطهاد الذي حدث
من قبل في عام 2019 ، رأى العالم إلى أي
مدى ستذهب الدولة لسحق
أولئك
الذين ينتفضون.
في ذلك الوقت ، بعد أسابيع
، جاءت السلطات من أجله ، ويقول إنه
تم جره من منزله في
منتصف الليل ونقله إلى ما
يصفه بغرفة تعذيب النظام
لمدة 16 يومًا من الرعب والضرب
الذي جعله يتعذر التعرف عليه.
بعض الصور المروعة
لإصابات فرهاد لحماية هويته ،
لم نعرض تلك الصور وندوبه
، لقد أجرى عدة
جراحات ترميمية أعادت فكه
معًا لكن السلطات الإيرانية ملاذ "
تركه وحده يقول إنهم يجمدون
حسابه المصرفي في بعض الأحيان ويتصلون
بالتهديد بقتل أطفاله
واغتصاب زوجته
، كل ذلك جزء من كتاب Playbook المزعج
الذي تحدث إليه العديد من المتظاهرين CNN
وقد جربوا
مشاهدة ساعتهم مباشرة من خلال كاميرات CCTV ومن خلال
رعاية الدولة.  المتسللين الذين يتم اصطيادهم عبر الإنترنت
يتعرضون للتعذيب إلى الأبد ،
لكن هذا لا يمنع الآلاف الذين
يخاطرون بكل شيء كل يوم في إيران.
الحكومة الإيرانية حول هذه
الروايات المباشرة عن
الاحتجاز التعسفي والتعذيب ومضايقة
المتظاهرين وكذلك الانتهاكات الواسعة النطاق
التي وثقتها منظمات حقوق الإنسان
لكنها لم
تستجب لطلباتنا للتعليق كراتشي CNN
Istanbul